l più di ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog come tutti i fottuti sabato
prima di cominciare allora devo partire
con la fonte la settimana questa volta
perché mi ricordo l'ultima volta che ho
visto una fan art così ragazzi non me lo
ricordo voi guardate che cazzo di fan
art è questa addio mio da me è la cosa
più io non ho mai visto una cosa c'era a
parte il fatto che anche i video di
sfondo
va bene è una cosa allucinante ed è
stata fatta ragazzi da me cazzo ti
chiami lisci il testo dal giapponese mi
date una pronuncia di questa cosa a te
ne teme ci sarà the music hall sarà
tecnici e magari poi si chiama giovanna
che cazzo dentro queste ore che possiamo
passare alle news ragazzi nello scorso
blog avevo detto che tra pochi giorni
sarei tornato nella mia casa di sempre
nei per fare video in realtà non sarà
così perché mi sono accorto che a casa
mia si mette molto di più a fare video
perché perché qua io vivo da solo
vivendo da solo riesco a gestirmi meglio
il tempo perché posso fare video quando
cazzo vogliono comunque questa casa la
cambierò quindi non abituate di troppo
al suo sfondo perché accresce la luce di
gesù cristo ragazzo sta succedendo fuori
ha detto questo passiamo alle 20 di
questa settimana che sono stati epici e
siamo andati incontro skrillex tipo una
settimana fa più o meno io e ai puffo
siccome roll o meglio ritardissimo avevo
una pizza da mangiare perché non avevamo
cenato siamo usciti di casa con la pizza
intera in mano e l'abbiamo divisa
metallo e l'abbia mangiata per strada
così a pizza si mangia così
come scrive l'ex fa dubstep è veramente
roba pesantissima e partito così
[Applauso]
[Musica]
queste scritte
[Applauso]
infine ragazzi siamo riusciti a fare la
foto con quel bel fustacchione di
skrillex è stata una cosa veramente cioè
io non so neanche descrivere la sta cosa
è stata un'emozione pazzesca e non è
l'unica cosa che è successo durante la
settimana che hanno fatto notare che nel
blog di los angeles che avevo fatto non
l'ultimo quello ancora prima avevo detto
questa cosa questa è un'altra stanzina
belli vino guarda me lo piazzo proprio
davanti mentre dormo quello mi piace
propria vita ragazzi con le bambole che
ho tranquillamente preso per il culo
guardatela bene c'è un film recente tipo
annabelle ecco questo che ho visto tanto
in gioca gata addosso in realtà alla
fine ispirata una storia vera che la
bambola vera di annabel è così ragazzi
porca [ __ ]
ho dormito per una settimana in una casa
con annabelle preso per il culo una
bambola fingendo che fosse posseduta
quando lo era veramente merda saltata la
corrente riga che cazzo è successo
perché mi metto a guardare roba horror
su internet salta la corrente in quattro
mesi che sono qua non è mai successo se
vi state chiedendo perché computer
continuano andare perché c'è una
batteria di riserva che lo tiene in
piedi però no fermi a tim
[Applauso]
d'accordo ragazzi ci siamo di nuovo si è
messo tipo 2 ora tornare alla luce ma ok
non so perché mi sono messo a parlare di
spiriti e robe del genere si spegne la
luce a cazzo bene dentro questo ragazzi
prima che si spenga di nuovo andiamo
avanti che è meglio che vada ragazzi c'è
questo sacco che mi chiederete che cazzo
si sa c'è una ragazza che durante un
raduno mi ha regalato questa cosa qui
piena di roba da scartare e quindi per
oggi ragazzi spacchettamento alla la
prima cosa che ho trovato è questa che è
molto maschile grazie cara e fantasia
sun degli occhiali non è
dai non è così male pensavo 3g dopodichè
ragazzi abbiamo una banana una una
banana al portapenne mi mancava
scartarle col c'era un motivo se mi
divertivo così tanto non ho idea di che
cosa sia ma non voglio mangiarla che ho
paura non è neanche ma dopodichè ragazzi
abbiamo un vibratore credo sia una
supposta alle grazie di averci un po
culo grosso per questa si apre è una
penna bel figo grazie cara mi mancavano
seco poi abbiamo un orsacchiotto con
l'uccello di fuori e l'orsacchiotto le
secolo ragazzi se li toccate l'uccello
cambia faccia e bellissimo guardano come
contento lì si tocchi l'uccello era da
secoli che non facciamo scartati di
pacchi web grazie di cuore soprattutto
per lui e che possiamo passare
finalmente luce a parte alfa vi risponda
prima domanda di oggi ma vi risponde
vuoi iniziare il video facendo una ruota
che adoro sei mio idolo allora iniziare
il video un po tardi però ci faccio la
ruota
qua mi risponde favi come sarebbe la tua
versione femminile di sicuro più
mascolina di me questo risponde fabio
visto la clip della canzone ti amo
inutilmente ci sei anche tu nel video
perché non ci ha detto nulla in realtà è
perché c'è allora c'è questa scena qui
che ragazzi credo valga la vita per la
ragazza ovviamente venuta solo sguardo
perché io lo sguardo sexy
prima di concludere ragazzi come al
solito direi di fare la paris domanda
che l'affare domanda di oggi m cosa
cazzo ci fa dall inizio del video quel
sacchetto di immondizia sullo sfondo
tara preparando un omicidio
favi cv o non aveva a parte gli scherzi
2 mai capitata una situazione del genere
dove si spengono le luci o succede
qualcosa di strano da farvi cadere
addosso fatemelo sapere che siccome
questa notte non riuscire a dormire mi
leggerò ai vostri bei racconti allora
riusciva a dormire sicuramente fatemi
sapere ragazzi ho concluso che
l'episodio se trovassi ma il telecomando
equa co.as.it ragazza il video è
piaciuta lasciato aumento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook che come ogni
video tra tante edizioni scorse ore si
scateni ci vediamo in prossimità
dell'area